Je pense que Catwoman avait une paire de lunettes super cool
dans la série Batman qui passait à la télé à l'époque
et je voulais être cool, comme elle.
Je ne pensais pas du tout
que les lunettes étaient en fait un dispositif médical.
[ Petite chose. ]
[ Grande idée. ]
Quand les rayons lumineux se reflètent sur un objet
et pénètrent dans l'œil par la cornée,
la rétine convertit cette lumière en impulsions électriques
qui sont envoyées au cerveau,
qui interprète ces impulsions
et vous permet de comprendre ce que vous voyez.
Les lunettes vous aident à voir.
Les premières formes de lunettes
remontent à 4 000 ans.
Les civilisations qui devaient s'adapter aux climats enneigés,
créaient des boucliers oculaires,
faits d'os et de peaux d'animaux.
Ils avaient de petites fentes pour voir à travers,
mais pas de lentilles.
La première aide visuelle a été la « pierre de lecture »
et a été inventée il y a plus de 1 000 ans.
On ne sait pas exactement qui a inventé les premières lunettes,
mais beaucoup l'attribuent aux Italiens.
Les premières versions des lunettes étaient appelées bésicles.
Il s'agissait de deux loupes jointes ensemble
au niveau de l'arête du nez.
Il a fallu du temps aux lunettes
pour qu'elles deviennent aussi parfaites.
Elles n'ont pas vraiment eu de côtés,
aussi appelés branches ou bras,
jusqu'à XVIIe siècle environ.
Les lunettes modernes sont munies d'une paire d'anneaux
qui soutiennent les verres correcteurs,
un pont qui joint les deux cercles,
de deux branches qui se glissent derrière les oreilles,
des gonds qui relient les branches aux verres,
et sur certaines lunettes, des embouts à la fin des branches,
pour le confort derrière l'oreille.
Dans la culture américaine,
le cinéma du XXe siècle a contribué à populariser les lunettes.
Le public voyait des acteurs et des actrices prestigieux
mettre des lunettes pour jouer le rôle d'un certain personnage.
Parfois, une paire de lunettes a été popularisée
par la personne qui la portait
et les traits de sa personnalité
étaient projetés sur le dispositif lui-même.
Vous aviez les lunettes aviateur,
qui correspondaient à une personne à la fois visionnaire et aventureuse.
Les lunettes à grosse monture étaient signe d'intelligence
ou d'un aspect intello coincé.
Le modèle Wayfarers traduisait l'image ringarde du punk,
hors-la-loi et asocial.
Les lunettes sont devenues si populaires en tant qu'accessoire de mode
que certaines personnes en mettent sans verres correcteurs,
parce qu'elles veulent représenter un certain attribut de leur personnalité.
Les lunettes sont cruciales pour certains.
Les personnes qui ne voient pas assez bien pour conduire,
pour cuisiner ou pour lire,
dépendent des lunettes pour mener leur vie.
Et il y a beaucoup d'autres objets dans notre société
qui ont été créés pour surmonter
différents obstacles physiques.
Et, seules les lunettes
ont été élevées au rang d'accessoire de mode.
Ne serait-ce pas merveilleux, si tout ce que nous utilisons,
chaque dispositif que nous avons inventé pour aider l'humanité,
pouvait être magnifié de la même façon ?